- I would go into agencies
and there would be closets of
computers and printers and
everything that they would do.
And so we started incentivizing
agencies to give money back
to the taxpayers.
So you know, when
you go in there,
what they do is, "oh, we
need more people for this.
We need more people for that."
You add a new program that's
not adding a person that's
adding 25 more people.
That's the growth of government.
And so at some point,
you go into every agency, you
look at every program and say,
what was the intent?
Is it still needed?
I did that in the
United Nations.
I went into every single one
of the peacekeeping operations
we had.
And I said, "what was
the original intent?"
Are we completing it?
And what's our exit strategy?
'Cause they had no exit
strategies to any of 'em.
We saved $3 billion
the first year.
It's just about putting some
good approaches in place that
make sure that they're actually
meeting the intended goal to
start with.
And if there is no goal anymore,
you scrap that program,
you scrap the people
that go with it.
And that's how you
clean an agency.
And then you go and
you put in something.
Or anybody that's in a role,
they can only serve in it four
to five years and then they
roll to a different position
or another position.
You never let 'em
sit for that long.
(light ambient music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
welcome to the first episode
of The Path to the Presidency.
Over the coming months,
I'm gonna be interviewing all
of the declared Republican
presidential candidates.
And if some Democrats get in,
I guess we could do that too.
And joining me to kick this
off is the former governor of
South Carolina,
the former US Ambassador
to the United Nations,
and now Republican candidate
for president of the
United States, Nikki Haley,
Nikki, nice to see ya'.
- Thanks for the chat.
I appreciate it.
- All right.
You're first out of all of
the people, well you were,
technically you weren't
first in, right?
Donald Trump was first
in, you were second in,
but you're first with me,
which I would imagine is
- Yes.
- Probably more important.
- Yes, you know, I mean,
look, I'm a decisive person.
I didn't need to wait.
I didn't need to wait to see
who else was gonna get in.
I didn't need to wait or
worry about anything else.
I think if you're gonna do this,
you have to do it because you
know this is what you want and
you know, this is what you think
you can do for the country.
And so we were ready.
And you know,
it's been a month and
it's been a whirlwind,
but we're working
and all is good.
- What were the biggest
things holding you back before
announcing, or the
biggest worries,
we'll get into the reasons
why you're running,
obviously, but like, what was
the stuff that you were going,
"ah, maybe I shouldn't do it."
- It's always only family.
I mean, family's the only
reason that you, you know,
you've got this when you,
when you know you
can fix something,
like it just itches at you.
And really, after the midterms,
I was like, that's it.
That's it.
You know, I mean,
it's how much more do
you sit back and watch?
And I've always been a problem
solver and I know what we
need to do.
I've been a two term governor
that took double digit
unemployment state and
turned it into an economic
powerhouse.
I was at the UN, I didn't
deal with one country.
I dealt with 193 and took the
kick me sign off of our back.
And I look at where our country
is and I see us falling into
this socialism and
defeatism and you know,
there's not an avenue
that we don't have
serious issues with.
And I'm thinking, you
know, I'm gonna do this.
And you know,
it goes back to the fact
that I look at my parents.
They came here 50 years ago
when America was strong and
confident and full
of opportunities.
I wanna prove to them that
they made the right decision.
You know,
I'm a military wife and I've
watched my husband and his
brothers and sisters go out
and fight for our freedoms.
I want them to know
their sacrifice matter.
Did it mean something?
And I look at my kids and my
daughter's getting married and
I see how hard it is
for her to buy a home.
And my son is in college and
I see him writing papers he
doesn't believe in to get an A
and none of us should be okay
with that.
And recently 50% of Americans
said that they don't think
their children will live
a better life than them.
I refuse to let that happen
to this great country.
I just refuse it.
So I'm gonna get in there
and do something about it.
- Are you shocked how
quickly things have changed?
For the worse?
I mean, if you take
Trump's term before Covid
things were good.
The economy was chugging along.
We weren't in
extemporaneous wars,
like things seemed
to be moving nicely.
And then these last two years,
and especially just this last,
you know, week and a half,
with all of this banking stuff,
it's like everything
feels unsettled right now.
- Well when you have
a weak president,
when you have the most
socialist president
that we've ever had,
that's what's gonna happen.
You know, America's
not strong on our own.
We have to actually work at it.
And that's the part I hope
that Americans take away,
is it's gonna take every
single one of us to fix this.
And in order to do that,
you've gotta realize a lot
of things have gone wrong.
And Dave, it wasn't just the
Democrats that did this to us.
There are no Saint Republicans
right now because you look at
Congress and all
of this inflation,
all the economic issues that
started with Republicans,
that $2.2 trillion stimulus
package that was passed,
Republicans started it.
Democrats have just
run with it after that.
But then what did
Republicans do after that?
So first they do this free
for all, they expand welfare.
So we now have 90 million
people on Medicare,
42 million people
on food stamps.
So they expand welfare
and then, oh, it's bad.
So what else do Republicans do?
Open up earmarks after 10 years.
- So what do you make of that?
Because when every time,
so Republicans usually say
we're for small government,
we're furlough taxes.
And every now and again
someone does cut taxes.
But when something like the
omnibus comes and they sign on
to all of these crazy
things and you know,
nobody's read the bill and
they know what we're all gonna
say about it, yet
they keep doing it.
Is that to you,
just like the definition
of what the swamp is?
- I mean,
don't tell me that Republicans
and Democrats don't agree on
anything 'cause they love
to waste taxpayer money.
- Right, right.
- And they have no
value for a dollar.
It's why I think we have
to have term limits.
It's why I think we have to
have mandatory mental competency
tests over the age of 75.
I mean, this is serious.
And then you look at the fact
that our debt is higher than
our economy.
We're having to borrow money
to make our interest payments.
I mean, none of this is okay.
And so Republicans love to
get on TV and talk about how
awful Biden is.
They started it.
- Yeah.
- So don't do that.
But we can put an end to it.
And that's the key.
And you know,
now they're looking at what's
gonna happen with the economy.
And Biden of course wants
to just keep raising taxes.
But what should they be doing?
Claw back the 500
billion in covid money
that hasn't been spent.
Don't put IRS agents on
middle class Americans
go and get that a hundred
billion in covid fraud
that happened.
You know, if 15% of
our budget is interest,
stop borrowing money.
We don't do that at home.
As governor, I had
to balance a budget.
At what point is Congress
gonna realize they are not the
only body that gets exempt
from how they spend?
- Are you telling me if we
increase the deficit and
the ceiling,
the debt ceiling every year
or two years or whatever,
that that might cause
a long-term problem?
Am I following you properly?
- I mean, look at
our households.
- Yeah.
- We don't spend more than
we make because we can't,
- It'd be pretty sweet if
you could just always up
that credit limit.
- You know, it's
amazing to me truly.
and I mean Republicans can't
say they're conservative.
You're not conservative
if you're spending like that.
And look, I've dealt with
that in South Carolina.
We had a Republican house,
a Republican senate,
and they didn't see
anything they didn't,
that they didn't
love to spend on.
And we called 'em out on it.
We called out port projects,
we called out the fact that
we had to pay down debt.
We went and gave tax cuts.
Like you've got to be
proactive and say enough.
And I think Republicans
have to realize, look, yeah,
we can bash the Democrats.
They have been awful.
They're socialists,
it's terrible.
But let's look in the mirror.
Look in the mirror.
And Republicans in
Congress need to say,
but what responsibility
do we take?
- Do you fear ever that
the cultural war has,
has been so lost that even
if you have all of the right
ideas, right,
so we can talk about
individual rights and limited
government and free speech,
all of the right stuff that
the cultural part of this is so
messed up and so many people
don't understand what the real
issues are and kind of
just do want the government
to do everything.
That it almost becomes
an unwinnable situation
for a Republican.
Like if you look
at the midterms,
it's like the Republicans
obviously should have won.
And yet people were
basically like,
well the Democrats are
running everything.
It's not that good.
But I'm not gonna
vote for a Republican.
- But I don't think
that's what happened.
I mean, I endorsed
70 candidates,
we raised $10 million that
went directly into campaign
accounts.
I was on the ground campaigning.
I think you had three
things that went wrong.
I think first of all,
you saw Democrats out
raised Republicans again.
- Yep.
- You saw the fact that
Republicans have to get it out
of their heads.
That you have to
vote on election day
if you have legal voting time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We need as many
of our people at the
voting booth as we can
eat when, as long as it's legal.
I want every person to
vote because we need
every single one.
And then finally,
when independents
and conservative
Democrats who weren't
happy with Biden, by the
way looked, what'd they see?
They saw Republicans hitting
on each other and hitting on
Democrats.
It looked like chaos.
We have to go back to what
our national purpose is.
We've gotta stop this national
self-loathing that's at the
heart of the culture wars.
And what started it, stop this
idea that Kamala, Biden loved
to say that America's rotten
and that we're racist and that
we're terrible to the core.
We have to go back to
loving America again.
Because right now we
look so distracted.
And when America's distracted,
the world is less safe.
We're seeing that.
But the national self-loathing,
I want our kids to love America.
- Yeah.
- I want our kids
to start saying the
Pledge of allegiance in
the morning and at schools.
I want our kids to understand
that this is the greatest
country in the world.
We have to do that.
And so I think that's
the first thing is let's,
let's stop all this craziness
and let's go back to showing
what loving America means.
And that's not with faint hearts
or watered down compromises.
That's by truly proclaiming
what we believe in.
And then our opponents
will join us.
And then the other side is,
if Republicans have lost the
last seven out of eight popular
votes for president,
shouldn't we say maybe
we're doing something wrong?
Shouldn't we wanna win
the majority of America?
Because our solutions
are the right ones.
We focus on lifting up
everybody, not a select few,
but how we communicate
it matters.
- One of the three things
that you just mentioned there,
let's talk about the
second one for a second.
the voting situation,
because the Democrats obviously
do ballot harvesting all of
this stuff.
You know, Trump is
basically running on that.
They stole the election
from him last time.
Are you confident that there
would be a situation where
states that are still doing
this stuff so let you know.
I know you don't have to
worry about say a Florida
or you know,
another or Texas
- or South Carolina
for example, right.
But should have
said South Carolina.
Got it.
But how worried are you that
California, that Pennsylvania,
the states that are doing all
of this crazy stuff, no IDs,
no signature match,
all that would even allow for
an honest and fair election?
- Well first of all,
I passed voter ID in 2011
and was vilified for it
by the way.
I mean the press said I was
disenfranchising voters.
They thought it was terrible.
And at the time I put the
marker down and I said,
if you think anyone
can't get to the DMV,
we will go pick them up.
- You put money in.
- We'll take them to the DMV,
we will give them a free ID
and we'll return them home.
25 people outta
there ask for a ride.
- Yeah yeah.
- So, you know, one,
I think voter ID needs to
be the law of the land.
That's not a Republican issue.
All people wanna know
that their vote is who it.
- But what do you do
about that before '24?
Because for Kelly for
example, it's not gonna do it.
- No, it's tough, right?
- Yeah.
- And I think the worst part
of it's the mailout balloting.
- Yeah.
- I mean that's the part
that I think is,
that the harvesting,
I think Republicans
are too nice.
Republicans have
always been too nice.
We need to step up and play
the game within the rules,
but also call out anything
that we see is wrong.
It doesn't mean we say, oh,
California's always gonna do it.
You call it out no matter what.
We're gonna force these
states to have to do it right.
Because if you can get the
people to say it when 73% of
Americans say that they think
you should have to show your
ID in order to vote
that includes Democrats.
We need to start messaging
that better and say,
don't let them take
your rights away.
Don't you wanna know
that there's integrity
to this process?
It's not gonna be easy.
- Yeah.
It's incredible because most
people do agree you have to
have an ID to buy
- Absolutely.
- A bottle of wine
and for some reason
you don't have to to vote.
You also mentioned
the cognitive test.
So I have to ask you about
the Don Lemon bru ha ha.
We can do it in two seconds.
But basically he said,
you're not in your prime.
- And I said, hold my beer.
Yeah, I am.
I am definitely in my prime.
You know, we made
Cozies out of it.
- Yeah.
- And it said, not in
my prime, hold my beer.
We sold $30,000 for
Cozies in 24 hours.
So we literally made
lemonade outta lemons.
- Yeah.
- I mean, look, God bless him.
But I have always made liberals
heads explode from the very
first time I ran for
the State House even.
They can't stand the fact
that a minority female would
be a conservative.
They can't take it.
And you know, even
when I became governor,
there was a senior African
American female democrat.
And when I became governor and
they were celebrating that I
was the first female
minority governor in history,
she went and she said,
"she's not a minority,
she's just a
conservative with a tan."
- Oh yeah.
- Like this has always
been an issue.
And so for Don Lemon to sit
there and do that, you know,
Whoopi Goldberg had
done it the day before.
- I know the Whoopi will be
one was actually worse even.
- In a way.
Oh, I mean, and then
the guy on MSNBC, like,
you know,
to sit there and say that I
was like trying to show white
supremacy or whatever,
they'll say whatever.
But it,
none of that phases me because
I know they're worried.
They know that I
pull from their base,
they know that I pull in women,
they know I pull in minorities
and they have always been
scared by that.
And so I know that that means
I'm a threat and I'll take it.
- Do you feel that
that's like the key part
of your campaign,
that you'll be able to get
some of the crossover people?
'Cause I was talking
about in my show,
there's not that many people
willing to move, right?
Like we sort of know how
many people are gonna vote
for each side.
And it's always about
getting that fringe.
I always say it's the, to me
it's the disaffected liberals,
it's the me of five years
ago that are like, wait,
the Democrats are
completely insane,
but could I actually
vote for a Republican?
Do you feel like
that's sort of your.
- So the interesting thing
is the reason that ha,
I'm a hardcore conservative,
so I'm not pulling them over
because there's a moderate side
to me.
It's because of how I
communicate with them.
You know,
Republicans need to see
this as a story of addition.
We need Asians, we need
the Jewish community,
we need the Hispanics,
we need women,
we need African Americans.
But you don't go
to them and say,
you should be with us.
You go to them and say,
what do you care about?
Guess what?
Every one of them
cares about their kids.
Every one of them cares about
opportunities for their kids
that they didn't have.
Every one of them wants a safe
America that's strong abroad.
My parents were
Democrats until Reagan.
Not because they were
really Democrats,
but because Republicans
wouldn't talk to them.
I just talked to them.
I go and talk to them.
I talk about
conservative issues,
but I do it through their lens.
And when you know
what their fears are,
and you can talk
about conservative
solutions through their
fears, they come over.
That's what Republicans
should want to have happen.
We don't have to compromise.
But you do have to communicate
to people that don't look and
sound like you.
- What's your policy gonna be
when it comes to the media?
I mean, obviously you've got,
Trump loves fighting
with the media.
You have DeSantis
who's basically saying,
I'm gonna ignore media
that won't treat us fairly.
You're, it seems like
you're willing to go in
and play with them,
but you know, you're not gonna
get a fair shake, you know,
if you're on MSNBC or
whatever it might be.
- I mean,
I'm gonna go do any TV because
if you're trying to win the
hearts and minds of America,
you've gotta go everywhere.
But if they say something's
wrong, I'm gonna kick back.
You know?
I mean, I think
that you have to,
you really have to do that.
And I did that.
I think one of my
first interviews was
with the Today Show.
And you know, Craig Melvin,
he was pushing back and I pushed
back as hard as he gave it
because I know that
my answers were true.
And they just wanna
change the narrative.
You know, a lot of
the liberal media,
the hate that they have on me
is they either want me to love
Trump a hundred percent or
hate Trump a hundred percent.
- Right, right.
- I'm not a hundred percent
with my husband all the time,
like, you know,
but when President Trump
would do something good,
of course I support it,
of course I praised him.
Of course we did.
But if he does something wrong,
I'm gonna call him out too.
I've always been like that.
I've always been a truth
teller in that way.
And so, you know, I'll keep
handling it that same way.
- So actually, let's talk
about that for a moment.
So it seems like a,
there's a certain set of the
Trump base that thinks that you
either abandoned him
or something like that.
I think we talked about
this once off camera.
So I'll just tee it up for you
to take it away from there.
- I mean, look, I had a great
working relationship with him.
He is a friend.
I called him before
I decided to run.
I love what we were
able to do together.
I think he was the right
president at the right time.
But when, and in the
administration when I was there,
he would do something great.
I'd support him.
If he'd do something wrong,
I'd say, "you can't do this."
And I'd give him options.
- Did he appreciate that?
- He did.
There was a great
respect between us.
And he would always say,
"well, how do you see
that playing out?"
We had a great
working relationship,
but when I see something
wrong, I'm gonna call it,
I didn't think he
handled January 6th well,
I called it out.
I stand by that.
So, you know, those
that don't like that,
I fact that I called him out.
That's exactly what I did when
I was in the administration.
That's exactly what
I do to my friends.
I'll do going forward.
And he knows that about me.
- Is any of the stuff that
has been played on Tucker in
these tapes and any of that,
is any of that changing your
feelings on any of that?
Or do you think there's any
more of a gray area there?
- So I haven't seen much of it,
but what I will say is all of
that should be transparent.
They should release all of it.
- Yeah.
- I think it's important.
I think the courts
need to see it.
I think the press
needs to see it.
I think the American
people need to see it.
And if someone broke the
law, they should go to jail.
And if someone
didn't break the law,
they should not go to jail.
I mean, we need to just open
it up for everybody to see.
- It's weird how so many people
in the media are screaming
that these tapes
are being released.
It's like, well, this
is public knowledge.
- They more than anybody
- Yeah.
In the old days.
Isn't that what they liked?
- Right.
They more than anybody would
always complain if things
weren't released.
The problem is they just wanted
it released to a committee
that was biased,
that didn't want the American
people to see everything.
If you truly believe
that, you know,
January 6th was a terrible day.
I think it was a horrible day.
We never wanna see
that happen again.
But if you truly believe
that certain things happen,
show us, show everybody
let us see it.
It will help your case.
But if you're not showing it,
then you're making us wonder
why are you not showing it?
So I think it's good
for that to get out.
- So I actually
don't wanna focus on,
on the former president too
much, but one more on that,
which is, so if you felt
that he was the right guy,
then obviously you don't feel
that he's the right guy now,
which is why you're running.
So what's your
thought process then?
- I told him when I called him,
I think that the country needs
to go in a new direction.
I think it's time for
new generational change.
And I think we need to leave
the drama of the past alone.
And I think for the
sake of our kids,
we've gotta start
looking forward.
I mean, look at the
foreign policy situation
and tell me that we don't
really need to be strong
and at the top of our
game and move forward,
look at our economy and tell
me that we don't need to be
completely focused on
where we're gonna go.
We can't keep talking
about the past.
We gotta get past that.
- How much of it you
mentioned, I mean,
we've talked about
the age thing before,
but is is an actual sort
of generational mind shift,
meaning that the boomers have
been running this forever.
Basically you and
I are Gen Xers.
Like it's supposed
to be someone,
let's say roughly
between 40 and 60.
- I mean, look at DC
- Putting aside.
- Look at DC,
like, that's why I'm so
desperate for term limits.
Like, you know, they
say experience matters.
Yes.
But then it, you know,
experience turns into
power, term limits.
Keep that from turning
into power and,
and turning into thin skin
and hurt feelings and thinking
that, you know, one
upping somebody.
That's what's
happened in DC now.
I mean, what has Congress
done for you lately?
Nothing.
- Not much.
- And so
- not much.
- What I think is get fresh
faces, get fresh voices,
get normal people in there
that can talk about what
Americans are really
going through.
And I think this is a time of,
we have to look at forward
thinking solutions.
The new things, you know,
the old conversations of
defense was land, air, sea.
Right.
Now you gotta add cyber to that.
You gotta add artificial
intelligence to that.
We've gotta have people come
- literally TikTok.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, so, all right,
so let's talk about foreign
policy a little bit.
'Cause I feel like
that's sort of your,
is that your specialty?
Can I say that's your.
- No, both are my.
- They're both your specialty.
- I was a two term governor.
So I ran a state, so I mean,
I can talk about the economy,
I can talk about debt,
I can talk about pensions,
but I can talk about
foreign policy.
So you pick it.
I'll talk
- Fair enough.
- Whatever you wanna,
- So you were the US
ambassador to the UN under
for a couple years.
The things were pretty freaking
good and there were peace
deal signed and they,
there weren't all these crazy
wars and all of this stuff.
Your basic policy is peace
through strength, right?
- Yes.
- Is that fair to say?
- Absolutely.
And you know, you look
now what's going wrong?
I mean, first of all,
you look at the fact that
everything goes back to
Afghanistan.
I mean it's really, you know,
as a military spouse, you know,
military families
sacrifice a lot.
Michael deployed to Afghanistan.
The idea that we left Bagram
Air Force base in the middle of
the night without telling our
allies who stood shoulder to
shoulder with us for decades,
I mean, is unthinkable.
Because that sent a
message to our friends.
It sent a bigger
message to our enemies.
What did you just say to
our military families?
I mean, Michael will tell you
you wanted to get outta
Afghanistan, fine.
But it's not what you do.
It's how you did it.
There's a reason that we've got
the highest suicide rate now
of veterans.
It was the biggest
slap in the face.
And we lost 13 more
soldiers because of it.
- How worried are you about
the military in general?
That there's been
such a demoralization
and just that the,
the woke thing has so infected
it and they're talking about
gender roles more than they're
talking about, you know,
battle preparedness
and all that.
- There is nothing
that scared Russia,
China and Iran more than America
having a strong military,
strong militaries
don't start war.
Strong militaries prevent wars.
We need to be focused on how
can we have the strongest
military, not what
they're doing right now,
which is taking gender
pronoun classes.
That's the problem,
is we don't have
our eye on the ball.
And Russia and China see that,
I mean there's the idea that
we are this week they saw what
happened in Afghanistan.
I mean, did you ever think
Americans would look to the sky
and see a Chinese spy
balloon looking back at them?
That was total arrogance.
And don't think it flew
over South Carolina.
- Its for hours, ignore
it for hours, do nothing.
- You watched watched it go
across and China watched us
watch it go across.
And it didn't go over
South Carolina because
it loves our beaches.
It went over South Carolina
because we're a military state.
They knew exactly
what they were doing.
If we did a spy
balloon over China,
do you think they would've
let that happen?
- Right.
- It was a national
embarrassment.
And so that, and then all
of a sudden Russia goes
and has, you know, takes
down one of our drones.
It is not what happens to you,
it's how you respond to it.
And America has been
asleep at the wheel.
We've handed China things
on a silver platter.
We're letting Russia run rogue
and we're not doing enough
about it.
- All right.
So let's talk about the
Russia, Ukraine situation
because I think you and I have
a slightly different approach
on this,
and we played a couple of the
clips last week when Tucker
had all of you, you know, the
potentials submit, you know,
basically your policy or at
least your sort of overview
on what you think should
happen with Ukraine.
From where, I'm at this point,
even though I fully believe
in peace through strength,
it seems to me we're so
screwed up at the moment and
financially so out of whack.
And we're watching
the banks melt down.
And we'll talk about
that in a little bit too.
That this sort of
endless pouring of
money to Ukraine where
we don't know where it's going,
seems really nuts to me that,
and that would be my first
position on all of this.
Before we get to anything about
territory or anything else,
what do you think about just
that position first of like,
- we should never send,
- we're completely outta whack
And it's like, how
can we help anybody?
We can barely help.
- We should never send money.
- Yeah.
- To any country.
Because I don't think you,
unless you know exactly
where it's going,
we should never send money.
I don't wanna put
troops on the ground.
What we do need to do is make
sure that we give Ukraine what
they need to win
with the allies.
And this is why it's important.
It's not about Ukraine.
This is about a war on freedom.
And it's one we have to win.
Because if we win, this
sends a message to China,
it sends a message to Iran,
it sends a message to Russia,
it sends a message
to North Korea.
If we lose the lesson as
dictators tell you exactly what
they're gonna do,
Russia has said Poland
and the Baltics are next.
We are trying to
prevent a world war.
This is in the national
security interest of Americans.
So if you go and
you have a dictator,
go and take over a
freedom loving country.
If we don't fight for that,
are we that arrogant to think
that we're not next or that
any of our other
allies aren't next?
The problem with people not
wanting to spend time on Russia,
that's the exact same kind of
thinking that got us in the
situation that we're in
with China right now is you,
if you don't show
strength to them,
they will continue to
push and push and push.
And I dealt with the
Russians and the Chinese.
They think the west
are the great sinners.
There is nothing they want
more than to take us down.
And you can't give
Russian an inch because
if you give them an
inch, which is exactly
what they've seen happen,
they're gonna go and take down
our drones just like they did
and violate international law.
- So what does a win
actually look like?
Because it seems to me that
Putin knows if he loses like
he's done, he's gonna
end up like Kadafi.
So he does have nukes.
I mean what does a
win actually look like
at the end of this thing?
- So speaking of losing,
let's look at where
he is right now.
How low has he gotten that
he's getting drones from Iran
and missiles from North Korea.
That's as bad as it gets.
He knows that.
They've raised the
draft age to 65.
The idea that last week they
didn't have enough ammunition
that they pulled
people off the streets,
put 'em on the
frontline with shovels.
That's where Russia
has gotten to.
He knows that he's
in a bad spot.
But the one thing he's hoping
is that China will help him.
There's a reason he did China's
dirty work by taking down
that drone.
He's trying
to help China and China
and Russia have said we are
unlimited partners.
And they have said Iran
is their junior partner.
That is your access of evil.
If we don't look at that with
clear lenses and see it for
what it is and be at the
top of our game on that,
that's what's gonna go wrong.
All Russia has to do
for a win is leave.
Is leave.
If Ukraine stops, they
lose their entire country.
If Russia stops,
the war is over.
So the focus,
- So you mean literally leave,
leave all the territory,
leave Crimea like the whole
thing or that is sort of a
foregone conclusion?
- Well first of all,
Obama never should
have opened that door.
- Yeah,
- But Dave,
if somebody came and took
Texas, would you say, okay,
we'll let 'em have Texas,
think about it from the
Ukrainian standpoint.
- California, I
would let them have,
- I know everybody says that,
but think about it from
the Ukrainian standpoint,
this is their country.
I mean the idea that these
men went to the front lines to
fight for their freedom,
even though they
were given five days.
The idea that women said,
I'm not gonna stand by and
they made Molotov cocktails.
These people have put
everything on the line for their
freedom and their country
that used to be us.
We used to fight for
a country like that.
Why would we not be there?
I'm the first one to say we
should have the backs of our
allies and we should hold
our enemies to account.
If you wanna talk about
what we shouldn't be doing.
Last year we gave $46
billion in foreign aid.
Now when I was at the UN
and we moved the embassy
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem,
I was so mad at that vote
because we had the right to put
our embassy wherever we wanted.
I went to my staff and I
said, I want you to do a book.
I said, I want you to
list all 193 countries.
I want the second column to be
the percentage of times they
vote with the US
and against the US.
And I want the last column
to be how much foreign aid we
give them.
I took that book and I
gave it to President Trump.
He lost his mind flipping
pages yelling out.
- Right, right, right.
- And what I said is,
I'm not saying you give foreign
aid based on a percentage
vote at the UN, but that should
be one of the things we do.
Of that 46 billion that Congress
approved that was signed
last year, we're giving
money to Pakistan.
That was harboring terrorists
trying to kill our soldiers.
That's now an ally of China.
We're giving money to Iraq
that's right there with Iran
terrorists that are
saying death to America.
We're giving money to Belarus.
That's holding Russia's
hand that's never been
friendly to America.
You're giving money to Zimbabwe.
It's the most anti-American
African country out there.
You're giving money to Cuba
that we labeled as a state
sponsor of terrorism.
We're giving money to China.
Stop giving money to
countries that hate America.
That's not what you do.
We believe in freedom.
You can't buy off enemies,
you can't buy off friends.
The best way to show strength
is to quit all the nonsense.
Don't give China money.
That's the weakest
thing you could ever do.
- Were you shocked how quickly
countries kind of came into
line once you guys shut
off some of the money?
'Cause you did do that last
time and then suddenly,
or when you were ambassador and
then suddenly countries kind
of were behind us again.
- I think if you look
at what Trump did,
which was, he was,
everybody's gotta do their part.
They need to pay their part
in NATO, they need to do.
I think that was the right
message because everybody needs
to pull their weight.
They can't just be America only.
But the other thing is,
we made sure that they
knew what we were for.
I personally went in and
made sure that at the UN
that those countries
knew what America was for
and what America was against.
I didn't care if
they didn't like me,
but I wanted them
to respect America.
And one of those things that
we were talking to President
Trump about,
we were giving 2 billion in
military aid to Pakistan.
We stopped giving
that military aid.
Congress has now put it back in.
The thing is,
you've gotta look at that
and say, let's be smart.
Even if it's helping a small
country, if it's a win-win,
you do it.
You treat it like a
business, it's a win-win.
You do it.
If not, we could use that
money here in America.
We don't have to give it away.
And so, you know,
when you look at
Ukraine, you know,
I don't want you given
a check to Ukraine.
And by the way,
there was no better ally we
had at the United Nations
than Ukraine.
- Hmm.
- They were with
us on everything.
I never had to ask.
They were the one country
that no matter what I did,
they were standing
by our side always.
So when you've got a country
like that and just as trying to
protect democracy and freedom,
you go and you fight for all
the freedom loving countries
because these dictators wanna
destroy any ounce of freedom
that exists in this world.
- So as long as we're
talking about dollars abroad,
let's do dollars here.
I mean, it's been a very
bizarre week with banking.
We are just so the audience
knows we're taping this a couple
days before we're gonna air it.
So God only knows what's
gonna happen, you know,
in the next three days
or whatever it is.
But you know, Silicon Valley
Bank falls now, signature Bank,
we're doing this bailout.
You know, my sense is
that most Republicans
are kind of like
"ugh, bailout again."
Like this didn't work in 2008.
We're just making things bigger.
On the other hand,
you want payrolls to be met
and you don't wanna punish the
average person.
Where do you fall out
on this whole thing?
- The accountant in me
always goes back and says,
how did we get to this point?
You know, you first have
to ask yourself that.
And then you say, okay,
where do we go?
How we got to this point?
If you flush that much
money into the economy,
inflation is gonna happen.
There was free money.
This was a bubble
waiting to happen.
Talk to any of the
Wall Street elite,
they will tell you
this was the easiest
money they ever made.
So then you go and you have
all of these people with free
money doing all of these
loans that they did.
And then all of a
sudden what happens?
The inflation goes up so high
because Congress spent all of
this money,
and then now you've got SVB
where they bought short and they
invested long.
- Yep.
- And in these bonds,
the interest rate's going up
and then now all of a sudden
there's a loss.
But the question and all
of that, so first of all,
you have to blame, you know,
Republicans that started,
you've gotta blame Biden for
continuing it and Congress to
continue that.
Then you look at the ball
that started rolling,
but look at where the rub is.
SVB isn't like
your typical bank.
94% of the money that was in
that bank was not insured.
Where was the San Francisco fed?
Like when you it all of
this was transparent,
they could see it.
So when you see a bank
is starting to buy short,
but invest long and
interest rates are going up,
where were they?
Where were the regulators?
So now you're gonna see members
of Congress come and say,
oh, we have to put regulations
on or we have to do this.
No.
Where was the oversight?
And does anybody find it
wrong that the CEO of SVB sat
on the San Francisco Fed Board.
- Or that Gavin Newsom,
it's now coming out
that his wineries,
and it sounds like his personal
accounts too were there and
he was lobbying Joe
Biden for the bailout.
I mean,
well, nothing with Cali
surprises me, I suppose.
But.
- I mean, so if you
wanna talk about blame.
Yeah, I would.
I would say go there.
So now where do we go from here?
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is the socialism
creep that I'm saying
is happening in our country.
The idea you're gonna take from
this group of people to pay
off this group of
people is wrong.
And I know that
they're saying, oh,
but we fired management
'and that, you know,
the bond holders
lost everything.
And these are the depositors.
You know what,
we don't reward bad management.
We don't reward when
things go wrong.
If a small business went
out, who's gonna save them?
Who's gonna bail them out?
I was opposed to the
bank bailouts in 2008.
I was, I have always
been opposed to bailouts.
It is a socialist
creep that's dangerous.
And all of these Wall
Street elites that say, oh,
but you know, all the
other banks are gonna fall.
- Yeah.
- They've always said,
the sky's gonna fall.
No, it's not.
You know what?
All the other banks will take
notice and realize what you
can't do.
And instead,
no one's talking about
the Chinese money
that was in that bank.
So do you mean to tell me
that our consumers who are now
having to pay higher bank fees
and get less services because
of it are gonna bail out
the Chinese companies?
- Right, so to be clear, you,
you would've just
said let 'em fail.
- Absolutely.
I mean, this is not one,
everybody will say
the sky is falling.
They said it in 2008.
You cannot govern like that
because if you go and you give
them a pass,
- yeah,
- The next bank thinks
they can do it too.
And no one's pointing the
fingers at the real group that
needs to be held responsible
for doing this with, yes,
it was management, but
where was the oversight?
Where was the Fed in all this?
What was their role
in all of this.
- Is in a way, is that like the,
the biggest reason to drain the
swamp that people think, oh,
we can just put
enough regulators in
these things and then
everyone will behave properly
and blah, blah, blah.
But it's like no one's arguing.
We don't, well,
I guess somebody
is, but like no one,
I think sort of roughly
centrist would say there aren't
enough regulators and that's
what caused the problem.
So that's why you have
to drain the swamp.
- No, and the amazing thing
is they're gonna say, oh,
but we need more regulation,
or this wouldn't have happened.
No, you don't need
more regulation.
You actually need to just go
say who was in charge of it and
why didn't they do their job?
And where was the outrage
before this happened?
Because they all could see it.
- So I happen to be more on
this side of the argument too,
because otherwise I just
see this as endless creep.
We'll just bail out everybody.
No one will ever be responsible.
And then we'll end
up with one bank,
which will be the United States
that will ensure everybody
endlessly.
But if you were a
president right now,
and that bank failed,
and you found out that I,
I don't know how many companies,
but let's say a hundred
companies that they were,
that were doing
their banking there,
now you've all of these people
who were just the employees
at the companies who are now
all outta work because their
checks are gonna bounce,
does the government
have any responsibility
to those people anywhere?
This is where it always pushes.
That's that push and
pull of small government.
- Don't fall for it.
- Yeah.
- Government was intended
to secure the rights
and freedoms of the people.
It was never meant to be
all things to all people.
That's it.
So when you go and you
decide to work for someone,
you never know if they're
gonna go bankrupt.
If you go and you decide to
put your money somewhere,
all of these clients at SVB,
these were not
your normal loans.
- Right.
- They had really
stretched it in a big way.
They knew what they were doing.
These were, you know,
risky tech companies that
knew exactly what they,
they were getting loans they
couldn't get from any other
bank, and they knew exactly
what they were getting into.
No, you don't change the rules,
you change the accountability
that should have been there.
And you hold people accountable.
That's how you fix things.
- Is the problem more
of an optics thing.
So it's like,
then Biden comes in
and he says, okay,
everyone's gonna
have their money.
And it's like the average
person is like, oh,
Joe Biden saved the day.
Everyone will have their money.
But in reality, that's not real.
- The way a real leader
- Yeah.
- Communicates the
facts on the ground.
- Yeah.
- A real leader
tells you the truth.
That's the problem.
We're not seeing, we're
not getting the truth.
We're not getting the
truth on spending,
we're not getting the
truth on the bailout.
We're not getting the truth
with this foreign policy.
No one's telling the truth.
And sometimes the truth hurts.
But guess what?
If you tell the truth,
you're quicker to
get to a solution.
You wanna know why this
country's so divided?
Nobody's telling the truth.
- Yeah.
I always told,
- and Americans want the truth
That's all they want.
Life is hard enough.
Just tell 'em the truth and
they'll know how to make
decisions from there.
- I use the Solzhenitsyn
quote on the show every day,
"all we have to do is stop
participating in the lie."
That's it.
But it seems like everyone
is lying all, I mean,
that's basically all
I do every morning.
I'm like, all right,
who lied today?
Let's go through 20 people
that just can't tell the truth.
Will that in a way,
be the hardest part of
running for president?
That, you know, no matter
what you say, and any,
any of you guys on
this side of the aisle,
they're basically gonna make
it up and you gotta just keep
slogging through that.
- No, I mean, that's part of it.
You know, politics
is a blood sport.
You don't get in if you can't,
you know, take the heat.
Yes, they're gonna
cut things up.
Yes, they're gonna tell lies.
Yes, they're gonna say things
that's already happened.
That's happened, you know,
throughout my political life.
But my job is to just keep
communicating what I believe,
what my truth is.
There's rumors out there
about all kinds of things.
Like what I believe on
this issue or that issue.
I'll just, you know, I'll
clearly tell you what it is.
And then people realize,
- I mean, that's,
is there something that you
think is like the biggest
miscommunication about you?
Or something that you think is.
- Oh, I think it's, I
think most recently,
the funny thing is that,
that CNN did this
article and said, oh,
she wants to cut off, you know,
social security and Medicare.
And the truth is, yes,
we do have to do.
And that's what I said.
I said, you, if you're gonna
be honest, you know Yes.
We claw back the 500.
Yes, we go after the 100 fraud.
Yes, we stop borrowing.
Yes, we cut the spending.
Yes, we cut the earmarks.
But you have to talk
about entitlement reform.
And the way you talk about it
is we don't take from anybody
that was promised,
don't touch seniors,
don't touch anyone
that has put money
in that has been promised.
My parents are in
their eighties,
I don't want anybody
taking from them,
but my kids are
in their twenties.
And you go to them and you say
the game has changed for you
because they know they're
not gonna get it anyway.
Let's start there.
Start with everyone in their
twenties coming into the system
and let's do a few things.
One, let's raise
their retirement age
so that we actually are looking
more at life expectancy.
Let's go and change cost
of living to relate more to
inflation instead of
just a cost of living.
Let's go and let's
make sure we expand
Medicare Advantage Plan
so you have more competition
and you run down costs.
Those are the things that we
could do that would really make
a difference if we did that.
Let's go and limit the benefits
that go to the wealthy,
because you know,
you can talk to people
like Bernie Markets,
they'll tell you,
I don't want it,
but let's go ahead
and limit that.
So, you know, these are truths
that we have to acknowledge.
Don't run from it
because of what CNN says.
Just go out there and
educate on why you think
what you think.
- So I wanna get into some of
the people you'll be running
against on the Republican side,
but quickly kind of
do the Democrat thing.
I mean, is it a bit of an
odd thing that you kind of
don't know who you're
running against?
Because to your
point, it's like,
Biden, is this really been
like, what is going on there?
I mean, what do you really
make of what's happening
with him and who's in
charge and all that?
- I mean, look, I
think that, you know,
it's easy to know that Susan
Rice is still in that White
House and that the old
Obama crew is still there.
But Biden has done an amazing
job at becoming much more
progressive.
I mean, than anybody
ever thought he would be.
I think you're looking
at Biden and Kamala,
that's who we're looking at.
That's what you have to assume.
If Biden isn't still there,
Kamala's gonna be
the one in there.
And I'm not okay
with any of that.
- Yeah.
It'd be kind of fun
to run against her.
I feel like that would be at
least a little more fun for
you, like the Biden thing, it's
like, how do you make sense.
- Of what that's, I
mean, that's fun too,
because you look at,
I mean, when you've got
got such a low bar, I mean,
that's not a bad thing.
- So, all right.
So let's talk about some of the,
the people that you'll
be running against
on the Republican
side, because everyone I
think is trying to jockey for,
you know, what separates
us all on these things.
So first off, I mean,
you could be on a debate
stage with your former boss.
Do you relish in that?
Do you, you know, I mean,
that seems to be
where he shines.
Like what do,
what do you make of
having to do that?
- I shine on a debate stage too.
I mean, it's just a fact.
- Yeah.
- You know, we're both running,
we're both gonna be
on a debate stage.
He's my friend.
But you know, at
the end of the day,
do we have different styles
and different ways, yeah.
I think that's gonna show.
- What about the
guy here in Florida?
I live in Florida now.
My life is immeasurably
better, as you know,
because of that.
Like, to me, he's done
basically everything right.
We don't know if he's running.
It sounds like there'll
be a little bit,
bit of a foreign policy
difference with you guys,
according to the
Tucker thing for sure.
But a lot of the other
stuff kind of seem similar.
What do you make of that?
He's, well,
I saw your statement actually.
You just put out a statement
that basically he's copying
Trump on a lot of this stuff.
- I mean, he's been a good
governor and I think that,
you know, I'm a
fan of governors.
I think governors know what
it means to run something.
They understand how
to deal with a crisis.
to deal with a budget.
You know, there's a lot to
be said about a governor.
You know, the only
thing I'll say is that,
you know, watching him,
like he took a,
did a total 180 and switched
on where he was on entitlements
and is now where Trump is.
He did a total 180 on where
he is with Ukraine and is now
where Trump is.
So it just comes across
like a Trump echo.
Well, you know,
then there's no difference
between the two of them.
- Could some of that
just be being in office
and how things change?
- I'm not gonna assume to
know what he's thinking,
why he's thinking it.
I just think that it's odd
that he is literally saying the
exact same things as Trump.
I mean, you see like,
the same things are coming
out and I think Americans,
when they look at it,
it's out where the case,
they just vote for Trump.
They're not looking for an echo.
They're looking for
like, for options.
But, you know,
he's gotta decide where he
is gonna be on everything.
I think you have to be honest
with the American people and
say, yes, you've gotta
acknowledge entitlement reforms,
but there's a way to do it.
I think you've gotta
be honest on, you know,
foreign policy that, look,
if you are gonna be weak
in the knees on Russia,
you're gonna end up with
Russia being just like China.
We've watched that happen.
We had republicans and Democrats
that got weak in the knees
on China and said,
oh, just leave them,
if we're nice to them,
they'll wanna be like us.
That is why we are in this
situation where they're stealing
intellectual property.
They're now in our universities.
They're buying up our farmland.
They're sending spy
balloons up in the air.
It all started
with people saying,
you don't need to
worry about China.
Let's just worry about us.
Well, you start doing
that with Russia,
and now you're gonna have
China and Russia there.
- So actually,
instead of with our remaining
time going through the,
the laundry list of
people that are running,
I think those are the big two.
So, all right.
Your feelings are clear on that.
I just wanna ask you
sort of philosophically,
I think one of the things
that I'm seeing bubble up now
constantly is that the people
feel that the machine itself,
that the way the United
States was constructed
cannot work at a federal level.
That the states are so out of
whack with each other and that
I fled California, that I,
I truly see no hope for
after the last time I was
in San Francisco.
I mean, it is,
it barely looks like
an American city.
It looks like a third
world country, basically.
- Very sad.
- And then I see how
things are flourishing here,
that there really is a feeling
amongst a certain set of
people on the right.
Like actually the,
the united part of this thing
is not gonna work anymore.
And that we should only
focus on the states.
What do you think about that?
- I'm a states rights girl.
You know, I mean, I think that,
you know, as a governor,
I think that the majority
of control should always be
in the states.
I mean, look, the
federal government,
it breaks more than it fixes.
We see that every day.
So, you know, as president,
my goal is gonna be
to empower the states
as much as possible.
Whether it's healthcare,
whether it's education,
whether it's military, whether
it's all of those things.
It's best when it's
closest to the people.
That's when government
runs the best.
When you have these behemoth
agencies that get so bloated
and so big,
and then try and dictate to
everybody what they should do,
I think that's part
of the problem.
We've gotta clean it out.
- What does that mean?
Like, to like,
'cause I think there's
gonna be a competition
for you guys to basically
blow apart every agency.
I can see it happening on stage.
How many of you will blow
apart the department of Ed?
How many are part like
EPA, blah blah, blah?
I mean, is that
what you'd go for?
Like really just like
dissembling these things?
- So what I did in
South Carolina was I
made sure that I put
people in charge of those
agencies and put people within
those agencies.
Their job was to clean it up,
get rid of the red tape,
get rid of the bureaucracy,
get rid of the people who had
been there too long that had
created these power fiefdoms.
And just in some agencies it
required really cleaning house
and some it required tweaks.
But you don't know, you know,
once you get in there,
but you have to assume they
all are bloated and they all
have it.
And it should be a number one
priority that you do day one,
that that's in there.
And that's the number one rule.
Because if you don't have
a government that works
for the people,
then you've just got
a government that
works for power and
that's what you don't want.
The second part is we've
gotta get to a place where,
as much as I love term
limits within bureaucracy,
you've gotta roll people over.
No one should stay in the
same job for 20 or 30 years.
- Is that in essence
what the deep state,
when people say deep state,
is that what they mean
more than anything else?
It's just the bureaucratic
layer of these people that are
sort of never moving
in these agencies.
So the president comes and goes,
but these guys are 40 years
in doing the same thing and
making awful lot
of money doing it.
- Well, you know,
it's like when I was at the
United Nations and I was going,
my first speech was actually
hitting Russia on what they
were doing with
Ukraine at the time
and the whole Crimea thing.
And so when I went in, you
know, I drafted my speech,
I was ready to go, I sent
it to the State Department,
you know,
just in National Security
Council so that they could
look it over.
They called back all upset
saying, you can't say this.
And I said, well, what part?
You know, what part's
factually incorrect?
And they said, well, none
of it's factually incorrect,
but you can't talk like this.
And I said, okay,
if you've got an issue
or a fact, it is wrong.
I am the first one
to wanna fix it.
You can't tell me
how to say something.
And I just ignored 'em
and I went forward.
But that's kind of, they
want you to do it their way.
They want you to do things.
But you know,
the reason that I was able
to do so much in the United
Nations was I went
in with fresh eyes.
You know,
I went in and really wanted
to break what needed to be
broken and see it
through a different lens.
And I've never held office in
DC but I think that same thing
needs to happen.
You've gotta go in and not
have allegiances to anything.
You've gotta build it,
build the trust back up.
I mean, Americans
don't trust any agency.
- Yeah.
- And so the number one
goal of a leader
is Americans should
at least trust what these
agencies are telling them.
And if they're so big and so
bureaucratic and so powerful,
something's wrong
with the system.
- Would you say
that's all a result
of just sort of
bipartisan bad policy?
Or is that really
just this, you know,
we did 50 some odd minutes.
We haven't said
the word woke once.
Like is it just that wokeness
has now infected everything
and all of the wrong people
are being hired for all of the
wrong thing, all of
the wrong reasons,
and nobody's qualified
to do any of this anyway.
- This was before
any of the wokeness.
- Yeah,
- This was the fact
that, you know,
I saw this in South Carolina.
Agencies think that if they're
gonna get the same budget
next year,
they have to spend everything
that they have and we put in,
- It's true, right?
It's not just that they
think it, it's actually true.
- It's true.
- I wish I could remember this.
- I would go into agencies
and there would be closets of
computers and printers and
everything that they would do.
And so we start incentivizing
agencies to give money back to
the taxpayers.
So you know, when
you go in there,
what they do is, oh, we
need more people for this.
We need more people for that.
You add a new program that's
not adding a person that's
adding 25 more people.
That's the growth of government.
And so at some point,
you go into every agency,
you look at every program
and say, what was the intent?
Is it still needed?
I did that in the
United Nations.
I went into every single one
of the peacekeeping operations
we had.
And I said, what was
the original intent?
Are we completing it?
And what's our exit strategy?
Because they had no exit
strategies to any of 'em.
We saved 3 billion
the first year.
It's just about putting some
good approaches in place that
make sure that they're actually
meeting the intended goal to
start with.
And if there is no goal anymore,
you scrap that program,
you scrap the people
that go with it,
and that's how you
clean an agency.
And then you go and
you put in something.
Or anybody that's in a role,
they can only serve in it four
to five years and then they
roll to a different position
or another position.
You never let 'em
sit for that long.
- So speaking of the UN quickly,
is it weird to you how
irrelevant the UN is now?
I mean, it almost is like
in complete conjunction
with you leaving like the UN
is, no one talks about the UN.
They don't, it doesn't seem
like they meet anymore.
Does the security
council do anything?
Do they even know what's
happening in Russia?
Like what is the
UN at this point,
except that they rack up
a lot of parking tickets?
- No, the UN is a farce.
I've said that for a long time.
But what's interesting
you say that is
I was meeting with Prime
Minister Modi in India
back when I was at the UN.
And we were talking about
at the time their alliances,
you know,
their military cooperation
with Russia at the time.
And he said, do you know,
I never paid attention
to the United Nations
until you were there.
But the reason that was the
case was it wasn't about me
specifically,
it was about the fact that
I forced them to talk about
things that were
uncomfortable to talk about.
I forced them to deal with
issues of the day and not old
archaic things.
And I called them out when they
were doing something wrong.
And you know, just said, why
aren't we talking about Russia?
Why aren't we talking about
the chemical weapons in Syria?
Why aren't we talking
about the Iran deal
and how they're violating?
I just forced them to talk
about things that were
uncomfortable.
And I think that we need
to have some uncomfortable
conversations in
this country too.
- Speaking of forcing someone
to talk about uncomfortable
things, I mean, who are you
gonna choose as your VP?
How about that?
Come on.
- No, I'll let you know.
We'll figure it out at the time,
but it'll be somebody that
makes the team stronger,
that's for sure.
- Do you have any
other final thoughts?
I think we've,
we've covered most of the stuff
I wanted to hit here.
- I think the main
thing is everybody needs
to put all of this
division in its place
and understand we're
fighting for our country.
That's what this is about.
Every American has to fight for
the survival of our country.
And in order to fight for
the survival of anything,
you have to love it.
We have to go back
to loving America.
We have to go back to love
the principles of America.
Capitalism has lifted
up more people than
any place in the world.
We don't need to go
into this socialism.
We need to quit.
Quit beating down.
You know, America, when I
was always tell the story,
because I think
it's fascinating.
When I was on the
Simon Boulevard Bridge
in South America,
you saw thousands of people
going from Venezuela to Columbia
holding their kids,
walking for hours in the hot
sun to get to one meal they
might get that day they were
killing zoo animals for food.
- Yeah.
- And when we got
to the Catholic church,
they all started
coming around me.
And at first I was like, why
do they care about who I am?
And then it hit me.
They didn't care who I was.
They cared where I was from.
In me.
They saw America and in
America they saw hope.
We need to appreciate
our blessings.
We need to remember what my
parents always told my brothers
and my sister and me was
even on our worst day.
We are blessed to
live in America.
Now we have to fight for,
so everybody wants to talk
about this political side.
Don't complain about what
happens in a general if you,
don't play in this primary,
play in this primary, see
America the way it should be.
Want more for your
family and our kids,
and our education and our
military and our foreign policy.
We deserve better.
And if we all commit to
it, we'll get better.
But that's what it's gonna take.
- Well then, I guess
I can only end this
with one last thing, which is,
I sense your future will be
brighter than Don Lemons,
so it's gonna all be okay.
- Go to nikkihaley.com.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna watch full
interviews on a variety of
topics, watch our
full episode playlist.
All right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification.